canelo alvarez reacts to kamaru usman  getting knocked out dana white lashes  out at reporters asking about jake paul  versus anderson silva sean o'malley  warns patti pimblett about weight gain  chael sonan tells conor mcgregor he'll  never be champion again ben askren  reveals what fight will get him out of  retirement sean strickland versus jared  cannoneer has been cancelled cyril gone  and tai tuivasa share a shui together  josh thompson breaks down the pressure  cyril gone will face fighting in france  and hasboola memes alexander volkonovsky  watch the full episode of thick boy  fight news available right now on thick  boy youtube